Hi, there.
My name's Holly and this is my human, Nancy Campbell.
Sit, Holly.
Sit.
She's really nice and gives me lots of treats.
Good girl.
How are you doing, Holly?
Nice to see you and your coming to visit all the children.
Oh! You're a good girl.
As you can clearly see, I have a really rough life.
Would you like to see Holly do a trick?
There she goes.
What do you think about that?
I get to spend quality time with some really special kids.
Would you like to give Holly a treat?
Okay.
Now you have dog slobber on your hand, don't you?
I'm trained and certified to be around little kids in the hospital.
Hunter, have you seen Holly before?
No.
And I only ever get as close as they want.
This is Noah.
Hey, Noah!
Which is sometimes pretty close.
Does she need some help?
Doggy hugs are my specialty.
Because really generous humans like you support the children's miracle network,...
...the kids at the hospital can smile a little more during their day.
So give what you can....
...and I promise I'll keep working hard to keep all these wonderful little patients happy.
Bye, bye.
Come on, Hol.
We're going home.